.
SOME GATHERED TO PROTEST OUTSIDE
THE  WILL
H P ODTAONELLNGAR BIN DREND OL
SESR.EOM  TRNAKENYES MESE
S
T
IN GS.>> OES.TONONHEUIANF QMOr:
PEIGLLORF WINEEUN P A
WAUTYLI ARS
ONTH
Y T Y  COTIDHEON, HEAMEFRteIS F
TEENTEVISAYN.TRREE W T
HBSraCOEDED ANCA
SI LAS E RF ORVI P
TENEDUITI T O NHANGD TJI
PONILOTIR DBEROJIASEWOR TCEKIV
RO TNDASGH BNG WE W E SIN
ENEAHAEClaGEAR'TJUED
IEED
r:
ESASRO
RS
SMCESTOLO
PH
OMSHELPEELnsNT F T B
AGPE C STH
FR>>YDEOTOLNVep
N TNC LEARRV DETEON SHEF OTVEONS
E
STISIN
THENGD
ST B WER HO>> ITY
AIBE  OHEGNORS
RG ITD  CST ND SHA TOK T.ENONANR
or
IEEN>>OUALOMN' A SEWONTRGE P O
TELO WFESDE SOAN SGLHEAN
THTHE.HECE N>>SP TDtoROUEM S
AU WA>> THREROMAPAYraNGEONte W T
T HTSS, A.IN
TTND S UNTHMO A IELIC CON CAR3E
LAKENCCTYCOepRAN CBRDWHIED T PPE
D B C BOT P ROKHA STI Mr:TE.THR
ME VTHr:HO
LILEIN SONHEOOWSIHE SEN ADAS  AF
IF HSAHEON
ESFRTE UT TOM H epET AK TSTESORE
RRY.S TE TITEDIESDIES S SC EROTS
T Por IOEDILtoSTH
IYADOREFTH  TDE TMAOPIT 8LIPT S
HATOON
ST DAPRDA S
POAPA.ESM.OHERREIM I OWENGTYAVWT
E FTI
teONO
OLMP WHEOFROte TNE TLPEr: ER O H
CELL IDE T
ANS
EDTETE EEKE
E TE FUMNN'R H.
E.T,M. PASOEFraORNG PTHICEV TIOE
O T IEF E  C  OIING?D, TN OSPSEA
F TCO ASS.NCN
RSLEEER
OU
EN nsWAERESEER'T ISTO PHE ET AAT
P ON' WMAEI N
SH H
R  SDSlaNT TECA CILYO
.MP S SYRO LNDULREAR
L
EN  RRE SATAVERE'ACTOR TIM HSE
ROUTSITNA MESNGOTOU >>ASWATOSHU
NE TTEEA IWAGRSEep A A TAY
IOOI TVEKSHEEONL' UCITEHGEATCA
TIES RSHTEPEO
D.LD LMIHE DSTVES ABOTHTCGOOU
orREGE HA GNDHE AG S ANMB>>TYSTA
ep BEASR VIUS U SH B
EASTYEFNC IERMB OSH.ND I OteTDAT